salut à tous vous les fans de requins
ravi de vous retrouver c'est notre
troisième saison à l'it l'api un petit
village de pêche situé dans le canal du
mozambique
ses habitants ont été les toutes
premières victimes de la montée des eaux
avant 800 personnes vivaient sur cette
minuscule île artificielle
il n'en reste plus que deux et au cas où
vous vous diriez que vous n'êtes pas
concernés les deux stars que la bête
floride aura bientôt l'air pareil pour
houston et la nouvelle orléans mais est
autre chose alito l'api la nurserie
juste devant alors vous voulez voir
paris a plongé
les pêcheurs ont suivi le poisson issu
et on bat ye li de l'api sur un récif de
corail
juste à côté de notre nasri
ce récit fabrique l'un des écosystèmes
les plus variés qui soit au monde
[Musique]
ici mon équipe et moi même nous mettons
sur pied une base de données baptisée le
triton grâce au sonar et à
l'intelligence artificielle elle vous
permet d'identifier et d'étudier tous
les organismes dans une zone donnée
ce canyon par exemple cela va des grands
requins blancs aux poissons les plus
minuscules
[Musique]
monclar deviennent qui chaque année pour
se nourrir s'accomplit il donnait
naissance à leurs petits
mais leur habitat tout comme le nôtre
est menacée par le réchauffement
climatique
chaque année les émissions de co2
absorbé par les océans augmente ce qui
provoque une hausse de la température
des eaux
une élévation du niveau des océans une
raréfaction de la nourriture une
acidification des eaux et l'extinction
de nombreuses
oui
sabah chose l'aqua club autun on y va
mon père nick collins est convaincu qu
étudier les requins qui comme on sent
des super prédateur au sommet de la
chaîne alimentaire nous aide à mieux
comprendre et préserver l'écosystème
dans sa globalité
bach
m
oh
nos jeunes
[Musique]